but I would say the most motivational
thing in my life over the years about
losing weight was actually reading Ali
Ross's TV column in the sum where this
pasty face little
from Aberdeen would regularly torment me
for being fat now I thought he was right
so it made me get fit so I think there's
an example where being fat shamed
actually can help it just cuts through
all the crap is that yeah you are too
fat that works for you but there's many
people you don't know their situations
you don't know where they're at you
don't know why their mindset is like
that and the only way that you're ever
going to lose weight or you're only
going to do that is if you can do it
that's true you have to do it yourself
and somebody telling you you already
know you're fat you I mean you have a
shower every day or a bath and you get
out and you see yourself in a mirror
right you know you know you're
overweight you could it's actually going
internally I'm seeing a lean mean
fighting machine exactly that six-pack
is shine and free thank you it is going
to be that point where you have to make
that decision